este ejercicio es del capítulo 12 del
libro de kotz trico y towns en química y
reactividad química para el cual tenemos
su permiso y dice usted pone dos litros
de agua en un contenedor abierto dentro
de su dormitorio la habitación tiene un
volumen de 4.25 por 10 a la 4 litros
usted cierra la habitación y espera a
que el agua se evapore toda el agua se
evaporará a 25 grados celsius y también
nos dice que a 25 grados celsius la
densidad del agua es de cero puntos
novecientos noventa y siete gramos sobre
mililitro y su presión de vapor su
presión de vapor es de 23.8 milímetros
de mercurio esta es la clave para
resolver el problema
hagamos un repaso pensemos en qué es la
presión de vapor
este es el contenedor a una cierta
temperatura en este caso a 25 grados
celsius y tengo un montón de agua
un montón de moléculas de agua adentro
del contenedor a 25 grados celsius están
moviéndose y rebotando unas con otras y
en algún momento tendrán la suficiente
energía cinética para poder romper con
los puentes de hidrógeno y todo aquello
que mantiene al agua líquida y las
moléculas empezarán a escapar saldrán en
esa dirección y luego otra y otra y
entonces el agua se evaporará
naturalmente dentro de la habitación en
algún punto
muchas de estas moléculas se habrán
vaporizado pero también algunas de ellas
chocarán con el agua y serán capturadas
de regreso al estado líquido ahora la
presión que ocurre aquí es la presión de
vapor como pueden imaginar entre más de
estas moléculas se vaporizan es decir
pasen al estado gaseoso la presión
subirá más y más y también chocarán más
con la superficie del agua y la presión
en la que el estado líquido y gaseoso
del agua están en equilibrio
a presión de vapor y aquí nos dicen que
es de 23.8 milímetros de mercurio
ahora lo que necesitamos hacer para
resolver este problema es entender que
nos piden
si logramos obtener cuántas moléculas
necesitan evaporarse cuántas moléculas
de agua se tienen que evapora para
darnos esta presión de vapor entonces
podemos usar la densidad del agua para
saber a cuántos litros de agua equivale
eso voy a escribirlo cuántas moléculas
cuántas moléculas
y agua
se necesitan evaporar se necesitan
evaporar
para darnos
la presión de vapor
de 23.8 milímetros de mercurio
entonces qué ley o ecuación bueno en
general no me gusta sólo memorizar
ecuaciones sino más bien entender de
dónde o cómo se obtienen y hemos visto
que hay una ecuación que de hecho es una
de las más utilizadas en química y en
gran parte de la ciencia que se
relaciona con la presión de vapor
también relaciona el volumen en este
caso de la habitación y como nos están
dando la temperatura y queremos saber el
número de moles
qué ecuación relación a haber piensa el
de tantito
qué ecuación relación haría
que relaciona la presión el volumen el
número de moles de moléculas
y la temperatura la hemos visto muchas
muchas veces y claro es la ecuación del
gas ideal presión por volumen es igual
al número de moles de nuestro gas ideal
en este caso agua por la constante
universal r
por la temperatura por la temperatura y
no debe de ser vista ya como una
ecuación muy rara porque en realidad
tiene mucho sentido si la presión
aumenta eso significa que el número de
moles también aumenta y suponiendo que
el volumen es constante el número de
moléculas que se evaporan aumenta salen
del contenedor es decir existe el mismo
número de moléculas pero ahora con una
energía cinética mayor o si la presión
permanece igual pero el volumen aumenta
eso significa que el número de moles
gaseosos aumentará o la temperatura
porque cuando se tiene un contenedor más
grande pero la presión es la misma
significa que se necesitan más moléculas
con mayor energía cinética de la que se
tenía antes y podríamos seguir hablando
sobre esto pero lo que quería dejar
claro en esta ecuación es que ya ha
dejado de ser misteriosa como alguna vez
se las presente ya no es misteriosa sino
más bien está relacionando la presión el
volumen
número de moléculas temperatura y la
constante universal del gas ideal
entonces queremos conocer el valor de n
porque si conocemos el número de moles
podemos saber los gramos de agua y cómo
nos están dando la densidad del agua
podemos saber la cantidad de mililitros
de agua que se evapore
entonces escribamos nuevamente la
ecuación del gas ideal dividiendo ambos
lados
entre la constante y la temperatura n es
igual a pp sobre r por t por la
temperatura ahora lo más difícil de esto
es asegurarse de obtener las unidades
correctas usando la constante r que
corresponda entonces lo que quiero hacer
porque la constante universal del gas
ideal que yo tengo está en unidades de
atmósfera necesitamos saber a cuántas
atmósferas equivalen la presión de vapor
déjenme escribirlo
la presión de vapor
es igual a 23.8 milímetros de mercurio
en el caso de que no lo sepan o que no
se lleguen a acordar una atmósfera es
igual una atmósfera es igual a 760
milímetros de mercurio
esta es la equivalencia entonces vamos a
usar la calculadora
tenemos 23.8 entre 760 760 es igual a
punto 03 13
esto es igual la presión de vapor es
igual a 0.03 13 atmósferas esa es
nuestra presión de vapor entonces el
número de moléculas de agua que estarán
en el aire en estado de vapor es igual a
nuestra presión de vapor atención sin
más moléculas de agua se evaporan por
encima de esta presión entonces
tendríamos una presión más alta que
provocaría que muchas de las moléculas
regresen al estado líquido estaríamos
pasando nos del equilibrio pero mientras
estemos bajo la presión de equilibrio el
mismo número de moléculas evaporadas
será el mismo de moléculas que se
condensan la presión aquí es 0.03 13
atmósferas por el volumen que es de 4.25
el volumen es de 4.25 por 10 a la 4
litros / hay que asegurarnos de usar la
constante correcta la pueden verificar
en wikipedia
/
0.08 y todo está con tres cifras
significativas entonces le pondré más
cifras 0.08
05 7
esto está en litros atmósfera por mol
por moore
kelvin
por mol kelvin esto tiene sentido este
litro se cancela con ese las atmósferas
se cancelan aquí multiplicamos por la
temperatura que estén kelvin y se
cancelan y nos quedará 1 / mol como
denominador que al momento de dividir se
invierte y queda como mol y es lo que
queremos entonces finalmente la
temperatura es d
voy a escribir los 25 grados celsius 273
es igual a 298 kelvin
esto es igual a 298 kelvin
por 298 kelvin y solamente hay que
resolver esto
voy a borrar esto en la calculadora
tenemos
tenemos puntos 0.31 tres atmósferas por
4.25 por 10 a la 4 x 10 está es
significa por 10 a la 4 pesos son litros
entre eso esto lo vamos a dividir entre
punto 0 82 0 57
mejor pondré más claro entre que estoy
dividiendo voy a insertar un paréntesis
voy a insertar aquí un paréntesis así
así estoy diciendo que estoy viviendo
entre eso y en el denominador también se
está multiplicando por 298 que elvin
cierro el paréntesis
y tenemos 54.4 esto es igual a 50 y 4.4
molist como les había dicho estos litros
se cancelan que el vino se cancela
atmósfera se cancelan y los moles en el
denominador se invierten y nos quedan
moles
mons ahora son 54.4 moles de vapor de
agua en la habitación a la presión de
vapor sin más moléculas se vaporizan más
se condensarán si pasamos del equilibrio
entonces no habrá más de estos moles
evaporados en la habitación ahora
calculemos qué tanta agua líquida es
esto así que el 54 lo voy a escribir
aquí 54.4 moles
moles de h2o de agua evaporados veamos a
cuántos gramos equivale esto recuerden
cuál es la masa molar del agua
es aproximadamente de 18 no lo recuerdo
exactamente pero podríamos decir que es
de aproximadamente
18.01 gramos de h2o aproximadamente si
quieren pueden buscar el peso molecular
en la tabla periódica pero yo me acuerdo
que por cada molde agua ustedes pueden
buscar en la tabla periódica y
encontrarán que en el hidrógeno es un
poco más de un gramo del peso atómico y
para el oxígeno es un poco menos de 16
como tenemos dos hidrógenos y un oxígeno
el peso total es cercano a los 18 gramos
entonces esto de aquí probamos a
calcular 54.4 por 18.01 es igual a 979
lo podemos redondear en 980 nos da los
gramos 980 gramos de h2o que se
necesitan evaporar para llegar a la
presión de vapor en el equilibrio
ahora si podemos calcular cuántos
mililitros de agua es esto el problema
nos dice que la densidad del agua es de
0.900 97 gramos por mililitro es decir
que por cada mililitro
por cada mililitro tenemos 0.9 97 gramos
usamos la calculadora nuevamente
y esto está recuerden a 25 grados
celsius entonces esto es gramos por
mililitro que hace que se cancelen los
gramos y sólo dividimos entre punto 997
vamos a usar la calculadora
entonces 980
/
punto 9 97 esto es igual a 980 y lo
redondeamos 983 esto es igual a 983
esto se cancela esto se cancela y nos
quedan mililitros
así que hemos resuelto usando la ley del
gas ideal que a 25 grados celsius o
mejor dicho 298 kelvin 983 ml de h2o se
evaporarán para llevarnos a la presión
de vapor en el equilibrio esto es lo
máximo que se puede evaporar pues si
pasamos del punto de equilibrio si se
generará más vapor pero también
aumentará la condensación del mismo
entonces a este volumen tenemos que
tanto como se evapora es tanto como se
condensa estamos en el equilibrio no
podremos tener más presión a esta
temperatura y encontramos que en 983
mililitros de agua se evaporarán y el
problema nos dice que se han puesto dos
litros de agua en el contenedor
y nosotros encontramos que solo 983
mililitros de eso se evaporan eso es
poco menos de un litro
voy a escribirlo esto es menor que mil
mililitros o sea un litro esto es mucho
menos de la cantidad total que se colocó
inicialmente entonces menos de la mitad
de esto se evaporará para llegar a la
presión de vapor en el equilibrio toda
el agua se evaporará a 25 grados celsius
la respuesta es no sólo un poco menos de
la mitad lo hará